liebes tagebuch ich habe heute das
dreizehnte türchen geöffnet und es war
schokolade drin
naja anschließend ein bisschen frühstück
um jetzt glaubt das ist so china horst
kiepe und voll und ein bisschen lecker
katze da ist der bruder ok bisschen
wärmer schalla eines konzentrier dich
ich brauche ich brauche etwas schönes
ich bin schön ich brauche ich bin ein
star ein ja ein stern ein einstein ein
stern ein ja das genau
ok hab ich da koks auf meinem daumen ich
bin ein star ein deutscher webvideo
preisträger verdammt ist quatsch ich wo
sie finden ok jetzt mal kurz gedacht na
ja ich bin okay telekom hier machen mich
ein bisschen sauber guck mal hier dann
lieblingsspielzeug habe ich schon mal
reingelegt und mal hier
wenn du jetzt denkst es lustig auch ja
ist so guck mal da ist das ganze kurz
eine wanne vorlag
ok havanna da ich weiß dass noch kein
wasser marx habe ich ein bisschen
schauer aufgestockt mit ein bisschen
kerzenlicht solltest du nicht okay neuer
tag neues glück ich habe das vierzehnte
türchen geöffnet und es war schokolade
drin natürlich ohne alkohol
okay noch vieles geändert werde ich die
katze kam bochum alles kaputt gemacht
hat das war ihr letztes mal die haben
sie anschließend noch ein bisschen
gebackener kaum noch vorbei hat mir ein
paar lange champignons gebracht ein
halbmond ist dabei jetzt um den abend
abzurunden wir noch ein bisschen harry
potter gelöscht ich habe das 15 türchen
aufgemacht hat das war schokolade drin
das ganze natürlich mit einem becher ein
oder in kirchen
woher box gar kein schimmer was das
heißen könnte habe ich guck mal was da
ist eine bedienungsanleitung zu wasser
und was haben wir hier ein kapitän spaß
beiseite wir haben hier natürlich kamel
eisen und wie schmeckt kamel ist die
natürlich halbmond für mich aus lecker
schmecker schmeckt absolut nachtrag
autocar dabei herauskommt ja und dann
ist mir das herz
das ist dass ich probier das x schmecken
verlaufen ob ich was auch in gesprächen
herauszuhören ist sind rosa pillen oder
sechste staffel mit kickertisch mal okay
hier haben wir schon mal mit pferden das
ist scharf aber okay das sind das was
ist das das sind haare und ein gutes
sind haare oder es muss probieren
das war schon okay nur das letzte
produkt aus dieser reihe irgendwas zum
trinken ich habe die japanische
anleitung nicht verstand deswegen was
zum teufel mache ich hier einfach
verdammt okay ich trinke das jetzt
einfach mal schnell
okay das war dann auch das definitiv
letzte geprägt was ich getrunken habe
super erfahrungen danke ich habe darüber
natürlich ein video gemacht das könnt
ihr dann morgen übermorgen nicht ansehen
hier noch die thermische fertig gemacht
mit den rest des essens als geschenk
verpackt und das ganz normalen platz und
nach so einem harten tag wenn sie dir
was richtig feines und bakuba fertig
brötchen auf foto gefällt auch also habe
ich noch paprika draufgepackt boom und
am nächsten tag habe ich das sechzehnte
türchen aufgemacht und das war drin
schokolade gefüllt mit marmelade und
hamm muss ja okay das video geht es lang
deswegen ja streiche die ich bis das
video zu ende ist
[Musik]
ich habe angst vor islamisierung sie hat
mir noch meinen letzten märz eine frau
auf durch die in unseren schulen gehört
und irland an den herd ich habe keine
luft auf islam ich will afd partys
meiner position bei den fall